it's comic-con time which means there
has been a whole mess of stuff coming
out at most of which I didn't feel like
giving my thoughts specifically Lam but
then the trailer for Wonder Woman came
out now that I want to talk about
so the first Wonder Woman trailer we've
gotten little sneak peeks of Wonder
Woman up to this point and obviously she
appeared in Batman V Superman and I
liked her enough that I was intrigued
but I was also nervous as to how much
the mood of Batman V Superman was going
to influence Wonder Woman because Wonder
Woman was way too far into product I
think was in post-production by the time
that movie came out or at the very least
they'd shot most of it it was too late
to like lighten it up or anything so I
was really worried as to how heavily
informed it was by Batman V Superman
have you seen the trailer I'm still
worried about that there's a number of
things in this trailer there's things I
like there's things I didn't like I like
the way it opens I like that we start
well first of all I know he's playing
Steve Trevor but that really did feel
like a very Captain Kirk thing with
Chris Pine there on the water and then
this beautiful woman going you're a man
that felt incredibly classic Star Trek
to me but regardless I think actually
Chris Pine is probably gonna work really
well has Steve Trevor and I really liked
her delivery for that you're a man
because it was this mix of awe and
Wonder and a little bit of longing it
was a really good reading for a line
that you really could have gone very
sour I really like the glimpses we get
of the mascara we get we got a lot of
little snippets of stuff that I find
interesting like there's this woman with
this broken little mask thing then
that's cool and in the first half of the
trailer there's some witty vibrant
colors that popped and I really like
that and then things get well basically
after she said the line it's not up to
you what I do which is a cool line the
trailer kind of went downhill for me
after that because then we got into all
the heavy action bees anything
look the action books good but the
action and Batman V Superman was pretty
good too but that didn't save the movie
and I did
action just all felt really dour and all
the color got sapped out and then them
oh god that theme kicked in and I hated
that theme when I first heard it in
Batman V Superman it's not that it's
like an inherently bad piece of music
but it feels so wrong for a Wonder Woman
especially for a Wonder Woman a period
setting no no but then they had the
little capper scene with her and Steve
Trevor secretary and I'd like to that so
I I'm I have a feeling I'm gonna I'm
going to the movie expecting that
there's gonna be mix of things that I
like and things that I don't like it's
just a question of what's gonna outweigh
what it looks like then kind of split
the difference in terms of her origin
which I'll take because I'm not gonna do
my whole ramp but I hate the alteration
to her origin that the new 52 did
particularly in regards to making Zeus
literally her father I really don't like
that and a lot of the implications for
what it does to the character especially
versus what her origin had been in the
previous continuity but if they're just
saying that Zeus brought her to life
like as a mystical force I think I can
go with that
I like the idea better that it's the
gods collectively doing it as opposed to
Zeus specifically but that I'm kind of
okay with as long as he is not literally
her father that again I'm not gonna do
my rant here but I hated that now I'm
glad they're not quite going all the way
there but it does seem informed by that
so we'll see what we get and I'm hopeful
for this and I do hope it turns out good
and I think she is a really good cabinet
gal gadot was a solid pick she and she
seems to be really good in the role I'm
just really worried about the mood and
the setting and the feel of the thing so
we'll have to wait and see until we get
some more footage some more trailers and
we get closer to the release but Wonder
Woman trailers out what do you think of
it whatever you thought drop something
down in the comments let's talk about it
don't forget to Like subscribe check me
out on Twitter at council of geeks check
out the council geeks podcast available
on iTunes and stitcher and until next
time this council is adjourned